they're the bowels of one of the world's
largest and most polluted cities where
disease runs rampant
and the stench is sickening human
excrement toxic waste
rotting cadavers all flowing right
beneath the sidewalk the sewers of
Mexico City are as disgusting as any on
earth but this man Carlos Barrios has
just given up a comfortable desk job for
the opportunity to swim in them it's 3
o'clock in the afternoon and Carlos is
pulling a dead dog out of the sewer he's
making sure that the wastewater of
Mexico City stays where it belongs we
pull up all the things you can imagine
you can see chairs cars all kind of
waste anything you like is in is in the
drains located in a massive basin Mexico
City is a crowded industrial Colossus
its sewer lines stretch for thousands of
miles
some following channels dug by the
Aztecs the sewers are severely overtaxed
not only must they accommodate runoff
from the mountains but also the waste
from the toilets and sinks of 19 million
people the slightest blockage can send
surge flowing into the streets and
Subway's or worse into the homes of
thousands at age 45 Carlos decided to
leave his job as an accountant to join
the team that keeps these sewers flowing
I have work for the city about 24 years
when I get bored of the office job the
opportunity came for me to dive and I
took him it was a great change for me I
changed my life completely
back at the base the team receives an
emergency call the Akula coal pumping
plant has a mysterious blockage and it
needs to be cleared immediately once
again the dirty job Falls to Carlos be
calm and careful
if anything happens don't despair I'll
be the one to make decisions we will be
very safe
he's Carlos's life that we will be
careful Carlos has no idea what to
expect
Julio's team alone has hauled out more
than a dozen corpses most of them murder
victims alone in his dark claustrophobic
environment Carlos must remain calm and
focused confusion can be death Carlos
tries not to think about the soup of
bacteria he's swimming in including
tetanus typhoid and cholera his suit
protects him but it is an armor a sharp
puncture could wreak havoc it is cut and
you could our skin also you have to get
to the hospital because of the
environment is very contaminated after a
half-hour search carlos locates the
obstruction there's a metallic object
I'm gonna touch it to see what it is
Roger the obstruction turns out to be a
rusty wheel from an old sewage pump once
they've located it the team makes Swift
work of the problem it's been a
successful mission for Carlos but before
he can undress
he must be washed and scrubbed down with
a disinfectant
in his new job Carlos has found a
renewed sense of purpose I feel like I'd
be someone who makes people live better
with infinite amounts of sewage to tend
to Carlos has got plenty to keep him
busy in the bowels of Mexico City